[Aplausos]
nanociencia y supercómputo
dos de mis pasiones
la primera hace referencia a cosas muy
pequeñas lo que vamos a explicar es que
tan pequeñas
la segunda hace referencia a un equipo
grande y poderoso busca cosa totalmente
contraria
y lo que quiere explicarles el día de
hoy es cuál o cómo es que funciona eso
en beneficio de la sociedad la razón es
porque cada vez que platicó o digo estas
palabras la gente dice eso que es algo
muy difícil complicado desde científicos
locos greñudos no no no para nada es
justamente la lo que con lo que
comenzamos es con nanotecnología
tecnología es una palabra que todos
conocemos no es otra cosa más que usar
los materiales comunes las herramientas
que tenemos en beneficio de nosotros
como sociedad la palabra y extra es nano
cuál es la diferencia que ahora el
material que vamos a usar es de escala
del orden de nanómetros y nuevamente es
ahí donde empieza la parte complicada
simpática pero que no lo es realmente un
nanómetro déjenme explicarlo de alguna
manera imaginemos un metro ya saben un
metro es como de este tamaño
aproximadamente compriman los mil veces
eso lo podemos imaginar porque las
reglas que tenemos de nuestros hijos de
niños tienen esas pequeñas escalas las
líneas más pequeñitas son de un
milímetro es justamente cuando comprimen
un metro
y es del tamaño de esa escala ese es un
milímetro entonces lo comprendieron mil
veces ahora tomen uno de esos pequeños
milímetros que tomaron y amplíen lo
asómense hágalo grande nuevamente y ese
pequeño milímetro ahora con primando un
millón de veces
justamente esa millonésima parte de ese
milímetro que tomaron de ese nivel
estamos hablando en la nanociencia pero
nuevamente dirían y eso es grande o
pequeño porque no es otra cosa más que
agua o si hiciera mucho pues bueno el
ojo lo más que puede ver son cosas del
orden de milímetros más tómense el
diámetro del cabello tomen un cabello
así vean el diámetro bueno no yo ya no
alcanza a verlo no pero ustedes igual y
alcanzan a ver el diámetro de un cabello
justo a es hasta ahí donde el ojo puede
ver quieren ver cosas más pequeñas tomen
un microscopio óptico un microscopio
óptico les permite ver incluso esta
bacteria sea se desarrolló la penicilina
usando este tipo de microscopios quieren
seguir viendo cosas más pequeñas
moléculas átomos pues ahora lo que
necesitamos justamente son microscopios
micros
los poderosos de transmisión electrónica
que se llama tenemos esos en esta
universidad por suerte pero todavía es
será suficiente con entender que eso es
un nanómetro hay otra forma de ver de
otra forma de compararlo quizá una de
ellas es tomen la tierra y nuevamente
comprima la mil veces igual que lo
hicieron con el metro y después comprima
la un millón de veces
justo el tamaño que les va a quedar es
el tamaño de una manzana entonces esa es
la diferencia de proporciones entre un
metro y un nanómetro y la tierra y una
manzana en otras palabras imagínense que
se le cae la cabeza a newton una manzana
y de pronto les yo les digo ah bueno
observa desde el espacio y dime dónde
está la manzana
quién sabe dónde está la manzana no
encuentro ni mis llaves cuando se me
pierden en el cuarto imagínense voy a
encontrar la manzana explicación a los
justamente es la complejidad o el gusto
de los nanómetros y otra cosa es esta
una uña que tiene que ver la uña con los
nanómetros resulta que las uñas crecen a
una velocidad de un nanómetro por
segundo si no me creen calculen
lamidanda cuando que les crezca un
milímetro regresa nuevamente el revisé
en cuanto al es tarde en el reloj que en
crecer ese milímetro y verán que crece
aproximadamente una tasa de un milímetro
por segundo un nanómetro por segundo es
justamente es de ese de este tamaño
donde estamos trabajando ahora bien que
es el súper cómputo el súper cómputo es
como el otro extremo estamos hablando de
cosas de equipos muy grandes que dirían
que necesidad de tener equipos de ese
tamaño si yo con mi computadora personal
puedo hacer el trabajo nuevamente es la
computadora la conocen pero en la era en
la que estamos en este momento es algo
que se llama las computadoras exascale
nuevamente el ex sky tiene dos palabras
metidas hay una es la palabra exa y otra
es la palabra flow
que no es otra cosa más que exa es es un
prefijo que significa 10 a la 18 y flop
significa operaciones de punto flotante
por segundo lo que significa es que este
tipo de equipos tienen la capacidad de
realizar 10 a la 18 operaciones de punto
flotante por segundo que es punto
flotante bueno digamos que son
operaciones matemáticas sencillas para
no complicarnos es decir una
multiplicación una suma una división
pero entonces estás supercomputadores
tienen la capacidad de realizar ese
número de operaciones en un solo segundo
y nuevamente es y eso es mucho es poco
que tan poderoso es un equipo de esos
pues justamente hagamos un ejercicio
sencillo agarramos nuestra libreta
empecemos a hacer un cálculo una suma
una multiplicación es decir hagamos una
operación por segundo hago tres más dos
uno que pasa un segundo cinco por tres
15 20 lo que de no no importa empecemos
a hacer operaciones eso es lo importante
de aquí no no aquí no se trata de que si
dijo si eran de 324 si menor es el punto
es hagamos operaciones a una tasa de una
operación por segundo cuántas
operaciones van a hacer en un minuto 60
operaciones cuántas operaciones van a
hacer en una hora 3600 operaciones van a
poder hacer en una hora cuántas
operaciones a ese ritmo van a poder
hacer en un año pues la grandiosa
cantidad de más de 31.000 31 millones
557 mil 600 operaciones por segundo y
eso es mucho nuevamente o es poco
vayamos nuevamente a compararlo
dicen eso es lo que nos tardaríamos si
nos pusiéramos a hacer toda nuestra vida
esas operaciones serían 31 mil millones
de años más de 31 mil millones 31 mil
millones de inspectiva mente eso ya
empieza a ser complicado pero nuevamente
ese número es grande
pues resulta que la edad del universo es
de 13 mil 700 millones de años en otras
palabras si vamos a ese ritmo
tardaríamos 2.3 veces la edad del
universo en calcular 10 a las 18
operaciones por segundo es decir olviden
no va por ahí el asunto para eso sirven
las supercomputadoras pero ya está como
no lo hagamos uno solo ahora trabajemos
en equipo pongamos a todo el mundo a
trabajar en esos cálculos en promedio en
este momento aproximadamente hay siete
mil novecientos millones de seres
humanos en este planeta entonces
pongamos a todos de manera coordinada
como si fuera una canción todos al mismo
tiempo hacer una operación por segundo
cuanto tardaríamos todos los seres
humanos los siete mil 900 millones de
seres humanos en terminar estas 10 a las
18 operaciones tardaríamos
aproximadamente
no
tardaríamos aproximadamente 4 años en
concluir esas operaciones es decir no
tiene sentido la forma de hacerlo
justamente es con una supercomputadora y
porque se tienen que usar súper
computadoras porque lo que vamos a
explicar son dos ejemplos básicos uno de
ellos tiene que ver con la medicina y el
otro con algo que también hacemos a un
método que hacer con un equipo de
trabajo colegas que es el tema de
almacenamiento de información en el tema
de medicina podemos tener nanotubos
nanotubos de carbón a los cuales se les
pueden poner dentro moléculas moléculas
de algún compuesto activo que les pueda
servir para curar alguna enfermedad del
cáncer en este algo hay una
nanopartículas de plata que son como
como si fuera el gel anti bacterial
entonces sirve para para que no se
se contaminen ustedes de alguna herida
etcétera hay otro tipo de nanomateriales
magnéticos que también sirven como lo
veremos en el tema médico pero también
sirve para el tema de almacenamiento de
información y hay otras cosas que tienen
que ver con foros donde ustedes pueden
almacenar cosas como hidrógeno que en
que sirven celdas de hidrógeno para los
próximos
carros que se espera funcionen con
hidrógeno cuyo único desecho sería
hidrógeno con oxígeno agua entonces son
de las cosas que ustedes podrían hacer
justamente con este tipo de materiales
ahora hay una palabra o que aparece
nuevamente que es una notera gnóstica
que es eso es usar nanopartículas que
nos sirvan tanto para hacer un
diagnóstico de la enfermedad pero que al
mismo tiempo nos sirvan para hacer
terapia pero díaz pero como una plano
partícula que no puedo ni ver que no
puedo ni ni oler ni tocar ni saborear
como me va a ayudar una nanopartícula a
resolver un tema médico pues resulta que
eso ya lo hacemos lo hacen hoy en día
hay nanopartículas de manganeso hierro
por ejemplo que son las que les inyectan
cuando van a una resonancia magnética y
de esa manera pueden iluminar ustedes
nos iluminan partes de su cuerpo única
del corazón etcétera que es lo de las
imágenes que aparecen del lado izquierdo
hasta arriba en negro no está inyectada
ninguna solución en medio para que se
encuentra justamente esa iluminación de
los órganos y a la derecha después de 20
minutos claros
aparece por la vida media útil que tiene
en estos materiales pero ahora lo que
queremos es bueno ya eso ya hicimos un
diagnóstico es más podemos localizar
donde se encuentra un cáncer con esto
incluso a mi esposa le tocó en alemania
que tuvieron cáncer en el dedo le
inyectaron literal y encontraron donde
se localizaba exactamente ese cáncer a
un tumor benigno por suerte pero lo
localizar y lo que y una de las
siguientes cosas con esas mismas
nanopartículas que se pueden usar
aprovechemos sus propiedades magnéticas
si las hacemos magnéticas hay otro tipo
de terapia que se llaman hipertermia la
hipertermia no es otra cosa más que se
sube la temperatura ya saben cuando
éramos niños nuestras madres se
desesperaban le dio 28 grados de
temperaturas está enfermo el niño 29
corre al hospital porque 29 grados ya es
peligroso qué significa lo que sucede es
que entre los 42 y los 46 grados de
temperatura las moléculas las células
mueren literal mueren es por eso es que
el ser humano también no puede por nada
llegar a esas temperaturas pero la
ventaja de saber esos detalles es que si
nosotros inyectamos
de manera localizada nanopartículas
magnéticas y de alguna manera las
calentamos localmente podremos hacer que
murieran justamente las células de
manera local y es lo que sucede se
inyecta nanopartículas en terapias
contra el cáncer y lo que lo que se
tienen en esas espirales son inducción
de corriente eléctrica lo que genera son
campos magnéticos y lo que le hace el
campo magnético que se está alternando
en una dirección en otra lo que ocasiona
las nanopartículas magnéticas es que
empiecen a cambiar de dirección y qué es
eso pues es como fricción se empiezan a
flexionar se empieza a calentar la zona
y eso lo que ocasiona justamente es hay
manera de llevarlo entre los 42 46
grados y lo que va a ocurrir es que va a
morir la célula y es el resultado que se
encuentra en la segunda imagen que está
en la parte superior donde después de
aplicar esa terapia
básicamente desaparece el tumor entonces
son son herramientas importantes que se
tienen y aplicaciones de cosas tan
pequeñas en la vida real que es la
medicina
como siempre porque donde entra la
computación qué es lo interesante este
no vamos a estar ni porque sean ratas de
importación conejos ni porque sean algún
animal a estar aplicando cualquier cosa
sólo por aplicarla es decir no vamos a
estar inyectando mercurio en la en la
sangre de los animales sólo para ver qué
pasa ya sabemos qué es eso los va a
matar
entonces no no va por ahí el camino es
lo que se hace con las computadoras es
probar con diferentes materiales y
observar qué le pasa a las moléculas si
ponemos un material que es una molécula
átomos de mercurio los ponemos junto a
las moléculas de hemoglobina etcétera lo
que va a ocurrir es que se deshacen se
revientan las uniones los enlaces de las
moléculas entonces sabemos que no
debemos de juntar esas dos cosas
entonces lo que hacemos con este tipo de
simulaciones que requieren cantidad de
cálculos enormes porque porque recuerden
que tenemos electrones protones
neutrones y hay que considerar las
interacciones electrónicas los tan los
puentes de hidrógeno y no es uno son
miles millones y recuerden que aunque
sean nanómetros estamos hablando de
cosas todavía muy complejas entonces
realizar todas esas operaciones requiere
el uso de supercómputo y la intención es
que no estemos usando materiales que no
tienen sentido utilizarlos ni siquiera
en animales es decir con la computadora
reemplazamos posibles muestras
de que pueden ser incluso dañinas hasta
para los animales entonces ese es el
tema de medicina el tema ahora de
guardar información que es guardar
información que es no es otra cosa más
que otra vez exactamente lo mismo que
hemos hecho a toda nuestra vida los
discos compactos lo que hacen es tienen
un láser muy pequeño que quema una
superficie de plástico yo que no la que
más y la que más es una perforación sino
la tema queda listo y eso es no es otra
cosa más que un código binario la que me
101 la que va un 1 0 1 0 1 y eso se lee
como código binario lo que sucede es la
diferencia entre un dvd y un blu-ray es
que usan láseres cada vez más pequeños
queman zonas más pequeñas y leen cada
vez son las más pequeñas y por eso es
que cada vez en el mismo disco tiene la
capacidad de incrementar la información
no es magia simplemente es quemar con
láseres cada vez más pequeños y las
series ya del orden de nanómetros y por
eso es que el bluray tiene la capacidad
de almacenar esa cantidad de información
con los discos duros es algo similar
sólo que en vez de quemar las
y lo que hacen es tienen superficies
magnéticas magnetizan la zona es un 11
la magnetizan es un 0 y otra vez tenemos
un código binario que baile' la
superficie y perfecto 0 1 1 1 0 0 1 0
etc eso es un código binario entonces
qué es lo que tenemos que hacer para
incrementar la cantidad de información
que leemos en una menor área puedes
hacer esas áreas
magnéticas cada vez más pequeñas y más
pequeñas y más pequeñas dónde está el
límite de lo pequeño el límite de lo
pequeño están en los nanómetros lo que
nos toca estudiar son justamente
nanopartículas magnéticas como las que
muestra en la parte superior en los
grupos con los que colaboramos hacen la
parte experimental que son imágenes como
las que tenemos del lado izquierdo y lo
que sucede es que ellos producen a nivel
de nanómetros a nivel de átomos una
superficie la ponen de iridium así el
material iridio a lo mejor son extraño
pero lo han escuchado pero lo ponen en
una cierta dirección cristalina claro es
la parte de hacer
la ciencia lo interesante de trabajar en
esto no es en cualquier dirección es en
una dirección llamada 111 eso después
platicamos del tema pero una vez que
tienes esa esa superficie ahora la
recubren con átomos de carbono y lo que
sucede cuando la recubren con una
superficie de este estilo es que de
manera natural se crea una sábana
corrugado pero que además no nada más es
cualquier corrupción esa corrupción
además es totalmente simétrica se repite
y se repite en toda la superficie y que
sucede entonces que nosotros podemos
llegar con esos nano clusters que son
mate ticos que son de hierro cobalto
hierro radio etcétera tampoco es de
gratis que sean de esos materiales tiene
su razón de ser algo que si lo que
queremos es que la energía de
anisotropía magnética lluvias o no pero
eso sea muy grande que es lo que sucede
en los teléfonos porque es esa es la
magnetización nos permite que si es
grande nos permite que si se nos cae el
celular no le pase nada porque el
magnetismo se conserva si se calienta el
celular no le pasa nada
se conserva pues solo sólo se altera el
magnetismo si ustedes le aplican una
corriente o un campo externo a su gusto
es justamente este tipo de materiales
tienen una un momento magnético un
magnetismo tan fuerte que ustedes lo
pueden controlar entre que que sea
magnético en una dirección o en otra y
además lo pueden depositar perfectamente
en esa superficie y cuando lo hacen como
es repetitivo y como tiene un magnetismo
muy grande por lo que tienen es una
memoria magnética lo magnetizan en el
nano cluster es un 1 no lo magnetizan es
un cero y entonces lo que generan es
justamente el equivalente a los discos
de memoria que tenemos hoy en día
nuestras computadoras igual así de
sencillas la vida así de
ok pero bueno al menos es divertida es
lo importante que es divertida y eso es
exactamente lo que lo que estamos
trabajando les digo no es ciencia
ficción son cosas que se hacen son cosas
que hacemos en esta universidad por
suerte y tan es así que hay imágenes de
lado izquierdo y está la simulación y
nuevamente es la verdad es que hacer
este tipo de experimentos es caro no es
fácil no es sencillo son aparatos
costosos por lo tanto hacerlo en
simulación nuevamente abarata esos
costos y es ahí donde aparece el tema de
de la ventaja de incrementar y lograr lo
que queremos llegar es a guardar
información en una pulgada de tal manera
que en una pulgada cuadrada en una uña
tengan un terabyte de información así de
sencillo y en cosas tan simples como
plásticos que las pueden deformar en fin
eso era lo que les quería platicar no es
otra cosa más que el tema de mis dos
pasiones que son los nanomateriales y
las supercomputadoras en beneficio de la
sociedad muchas gracias